je dirige un cabinet d'architecture
signe particulier vit un conte de fées
en fait il racontait des histoires le
soir qui était histoires aimantes et
tout le monde disait mais écrit dans de
Dieu c'est renversant quand même vous
dites mais je me réveiller
c'était un phénomène c'est le français
le plus vendu dans le monde
je le trouve extrêmement riche de la
connaissance qu'il a des sentiments les
hommes et des femmes
étaient très dures elle a été très très
dure j'ai pas m'excuser d'écrire tu vois
personne n'est obligé de l'acheter le
bouquin et encore moins de le lire
on a quand même chose à reconnaître
c'est que c'est quand même une carrière
hallucinante
[Musique]